[Music]
5 14 on your friday morning what's cool
at school how about middle and junior
high school students building models of
imaginary cities from the future to try
to solve today's problems using
engineering principles that they learn
from volunteer mentors wow that's that's
a mouthful but but hang on there's more
those future cities are built using only
recycled household stuff and heaping
helpings of imagination to write and
memorize a seven-minute script like hyde
park middle school's seventh graders
yash vin and vish the first time she
ever created shall i press the button
yes you see josh and vin are from the
year 2122 no way that's so cool you guys
came into a time machine who stumble
into our time why does the bay look like
a dumping ground that's because the
sewage from the industry is flowing into
the ocean we come from the waste is
recycled we reuse their presentation
takes fish back to the future how do you
deal with all the plastic producing
well our plastic is used in the
infrastructure and all the buildings
along with diets used in our roads and
day-to-day items like clothing students
are judged not only on their
presentation and the model of their city
but also on essays describing their
solutions to some of today's thorniest
issues
josh vin and vish found out how they did
in a zoo meeting earlier this week
winner of the 2022
virtual nevada future city competition
is
xing
from hyde park middle school
yay
now before the pandemic local winners
got a trip to washington d.c for the
national competition but like a lot of
things in the pandemic that too is going
to be online but congratulations anyway
not only to those hyde park kids but to
all the students in the competition and
their parents and their teachers and
administrators who give us hope for a
brighter future if you know something
that's cool at school let us know now
coolant school is under the community
tab on eight newsnow dot com or you can
just send us an email cool at school at
eight newsnow dot com and full
disclosure john and heather and sherry
ten
years ago in 2012 my son was on a team
that won
the future city competition from hyde
park and we did get to go to our
nation's capitol it was the coolest
experience but these kids are learning
about infrastructure how cities are
built and how they work when a lot of
other kids just go through life not even
knowing what any of that is right and
made out of recycled plastic our
infrastructure yeah they these kids have
got it on the ball practical knowledge
yeah it's really cool so what what guy
uh won for whatever was 10 years ago has
that become reality uh but you also get
public speaking skills oh no their city
was called tri-land and they were
talking about recycling waste water and
how to make that work better
okay so i think we're doing some of that
yes
all right
see guy tannenbaum